A qué demanda se refiere el presidente
borich que eran clave en las protestas y
que no han tenido respuesta
Hola Valentina Muy buenas tardes en
particular han habido dos o tres
reformas o demandas desde la ciudadanía
muy importantes respecto al sistema de
pensiones respecto al sistema de salud y
también respecto a un sistema general de
seguridad de seguridad social o
seguridad de retiro no El Ejecutivo ha
presentado propuesta al respecto sin
embargo producto de que no cuenta con
mayoría es necesarias ni mínimas por
cierto para llevar adelante estas
medidas no ha logrado materializar estas
propuestas o estos mensajes en políticas
públicas
bueno sabemos que una de las claves fue
la asamblea constitucional uno de los
resultados de esta movilización y el
texto resultante fue rechazado por los
chilenos Cómo se ve la imagen del
gobierno y de las autoridades con esta
situación
efectivamente lo que Nosotros llamamos
el plebiscito es salir en donde la
ciudadanía tuvimos la oportunidad de
aprobados rechazar este texto propuesto
contó con varias características la
primera Perdón una sin precedente en los
últimos 30 años de nuestra historia
democrática en donde participa gran
parte del electorado por un voto
obligatorio con más de 13 millones de
votos emitidos teniendo en cuenta que en
general participan sellos siete millones
de lectores y además sumado eso un
amplio porcentaje en rechazo la
propuesta constitucional con
anterioridad a esto el gobierno
efectivamente había asumido como propio
el compromiso de comunicar llevar
adelante y promocionar la propuesta de
texto constitucional por lo tanto la
interpretación de este de este resultado
es que no solamente se rechaza la
propuesta constitucional sino que
también se evalúa en términos políticos
como un voto de rechazo hacia el
gobierno no hace su gestión quienes los
meses anteriores se había abocado por
completo a promover y difundir la
propuesta negro bueno la ong amnistía
internacional denuncia que han pasado
tres años del estallido y el papel de
las autoridades se ha caracterizado por
la lentitud en los procesos judiciales
abiertos por violaciones a los Derechos
Humanos justamente en las movilizaciones
qué es lo que ocurre con la justicia en
Chile
bueno la división de poderes sea
respetado como tal tanto El poder
legislativo como El Ejecutivo se cuida
mucho de no criticar la el desempeño del
poder judicial pero efectivamente hoy en
día por ejemplo una una cena una una
actual senadora en ejercicio que fue
mutilada en su de sus ojos producto de
la represión de carabineros dando cuenta
la ciudadanía habla que aproximadamente
10.000 denuncias hechas menos de un 1%
de estas ha tenido una solución una
sanción judicial por lo tanto
efectivamente el sistema judicial
chileno es tarde respecto de estos
procesos también quiero ser súper
transparente y muere sobre la mesa que
también desde el punto de vista judicial
tanto nacional como internacional nos
han comprobado judicial o jurídicamente
esta violación sistemática los Derechos
Humanos sin embargo la evidencia nos
muestra que cientos de ciudadanos y
ciudadanas fueron no solamente dejados
sino que también mutilados con parte de
su cuerpo